- Remember that time we ate
12 Pop-Tarts in one sitting?
It's right now.
- Oh yeah.
(laughter)
(record scratch)
- Today we're trying Jolly
Rancher-flavored Pop-Tarts!
- I'm excited to see these
two combos come together,
Jolly Ranchers and Pop-Tarts.
- I used to eat the S'mores one,
the Cinnamon one, the Strawberry one.
I love all of them.
- As a kid, my teacher used
to throw Jolly Ranchers
as prizes if you get an answer right.
- I used to be a avid Pop-Tart eater.
Like, I was on top of it,
and the strawberry flavor was my jam.
No pun intended.
- I already like the
design of the Pop-Tart.
It's so '90s.
- It really is.
- If Dr. Seuss was made into
a pastry, this would be it.
- They smell like those
chewable Jolly Ranchers.
- Yeah.
Smells good.
- It tastes identical to a Jolly
Rancher, like, super sweet.
- I don't know if the combo works for me.
- This is every kid's dream.
- I like it.
- Mhmm.
I feel like a child eating this,
and I'm not afraid to
admit that I like it.
- Green Apple, always a classic.
Oh my god!
- Wow, it's strong.
- It's so strong.
- [Female Taster] It's
stronger than the Watermelon.
- All right, let's try it.
Oh, that's sour.
Holy shit!
- Too much flavor.
I keep scrunching my face.
- And yet, I wanna take another bite.
- I have to be in some kind
of mood to wanna have this
because it's so sour.
- 10 out of 10!
I've never tasted a Pop-Tart this good.
This is exactly like
the green Jolly Rancher.
This is amazing.
- [Female Taster] It's
like a Valentine Pop-Tart.
- I kinda miss the sprinkles,
like the traditional sprinkles.
- Out of all the other Pop-Tarts,
this is the best-designed Pop-Tart.
- You can't even talk about Jolly Ranchers
without at least talking about cherry.
I mean, come on now.
One, two, three.
This is gonna be a hard no.
- It tastes like Valentine's Day.
I see teddy bears and rose
petals and red balloons.
- It doesn't taste like medicine.
- Yeah, it doesn't taste like medicine.
It doesn't taste fake.
- This would be good, you know,
take this on a Valentine's Day breakfast.
- I think your date would dump you.
- [Male Taster] The
watermelon took the slice.
- Yes it did!
- It was a clear winner today.
- If you're looking for a deviation
from the typical fruity Pop-Tarts,
I'd say that's the one to go to.
- My favorite one was Cherry
because it had the best ratio
of the Pop-Tart to the candy,
and it tasted the least fake to me.
- Watermelon was by far the best.
I would eat that at
home, now, as an adult.
- Honestly, don't try to
make Watermelon a Pop-Tart.
It was good, but it wasn't great.
- Bring us Grape.
- Bring the Grape.
And maybe Peach.
- And Lemon.
- Oh, Lemon would be good, I think.
That'd be nice.
(upbeat retro music)